I'm gonna make Carla watch your back
guys what's up everybody this is Dave
fails I'm Kate Quigley I have my
goofball bestie and sometimes co-host
Eric Myers with me say hi Eric greetings
and salutations it's a lovely day why do
you talk like a cartoon character on the
podcast but nice I don't know I'm trying
to be animated I'm silly I love you I'm
an entertainer Kate clearly I like is
that a new hat that Dodgers had I've
never seen you in a Dodgers hat before I
got a new hat in Las Vegas because there
was a hundred and eighteen and my little
face was getting burnt and I walked to
the mall from the stratosphere and it
was two miles and I'm most freakin died
heartland it was cooked like almost I
would cook like bacon you look amazing
well yes I do I have excellent bone
structure you guys know him of course
the comedian actor he's very funny and
he has a podcast you can check out
called the Harlan Highway Harlan
Williams I was going to introduce you as
Larry from Fresno we uh we did a show
together like a week ago or something at
the Comedy Store and I was hosting and
he said to bring him up as Larry from
Fresno which you've done that before to
me at other places yeah and but what's
really funny is a I'm backstage like I
think he was on stage or I don't know
and somebody text me and they go hey
what's that where you guys Instagram
he's really funny I want to follow that
guy he had a lot of polished material it
was his first time on stage very such a
great comedy punchline name my friend
Larry pres there's a great comedy town
town definitely know I don't know if you
remember the first time I ever met you I
doubt that you do so this was maybe like
two or three Christmases ago I maybe
three years ago I was co M seeing a show
at The Comedy Store for Oh God it was
for charity
a troupes charity I can't remember how
I'm saying yeah it was like me and court
McGowan and court was dressed up as mr.
Koz and I was dressed up as like mrs.
like dirty a dirty mrs. Claus this is
what I did okay this actually goes to
show you like how this is like how they
can sex up any outfit with the dirty
Smokey the Bear I'll be honest with you
this is what happened there was this
show I heard about at The Comedy Store
and it was um I wish I could remember
the name of the charity but anyways it
was something for the the like Wounded
Warrior Foundation that's what it was so
I had some buddies that were putting
together the show and they already had
it all booked and it was like you Bobby
Lee Dane Cook
I can't remember a bunch of huge Russell
Peters I think was on it and I was like
I gotta find a way to like get on that
show like I said do something on that
show there's such a good lineup like
what could I do so I hit them up and I
go hey if you guys want I have like a
really [ __ ] like mrs. cause outfit I
could wear and I feel like courts like
dirty courts like dirty sidekick like
dirty missus cause and they were like
really you would do you would do that
that's so sweet like they thought I was
being nice like but I was like yeah the
troops are out there on the inside I was
like I can get on stage with these guys
like that's that's great
so I messaged him and they were like
great yeah that'd be awesome so I did I
dressed up as that and I was there and
that's the first time I ever met you
there's really brief though it was like
for two minutes maybe but then it was
also the first time I ever saw you
perform and you were so funny I mean
like of that whole lineup I remember
telling people I was like dude Harlan
Williams like this lineup was like sick
and he like blew everyone away like your
crowd work was so funny I mean I was
like a huge I was like an instant fan
thank you I don't remember meeting you
though you do yeah
oh that's so funny I didn't think that
you would yeah I remember just for a
second I think yeah I ever met you in
the back room and you were dressed a
little I remember it was a long time ago
was a few years ago years ago was it to
- yeah okay he's like I remember the
moment it was 2 years 7 days but I saw
mrs. Claus that was really fun though I
mean like you were kind you're so funny
I feel like
you Carlin do you feel like you were I'm
not gonna say all T before all T was
cool cuz obviously there was like emo
Philips the stuff that we're all T back
in the day or even like Gallagher what
but like do you feel like you were an
ulti comic when it wasn't as like in as
it is now where everybody trying to do
the all t thing but you were probably
maybe 10 years before the big where
everybody's trying to be loyalty now and
all that kind of stuff I got I guess so
I mean I was never trying to be anything
really just what I just trying to do
whatever came to me that was just her
sense of humor yeah so I you know maybe
some of it was all T some of it was I
don't know I was always experimenting
cuz you always that your crowd work is
all team but you don't ever seen anybody
really do all t crab up or your
consummate in the crowd and then call
them like a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich it's also genius because it's
stuff that I think your actors kind of
like mine where it's like you don't want
to offend people you don't wanna push
you to base hot but you're nicer so your
crowd work is is never mean you're never
like oh you're from Iowa you're a stupid
[ __ ] that you're just like oh you're
from Iowa that must mean you're right
around a moose or it's very playful and
and and kind of surreal almost yeah I
really love that and you really go
seamlessly in between that and getting
your material yeah I agree with what you
said you you know you don't want to hurt
people's feelings right there - laughs
right
so I'm the same like hate I can't be
mean I actually can't I literally can't
do it like I mean if I it's actually I
wanted to make a sketch about this
because I play a lot of sports and I'm
terrible at smack talk cuz whenever I
try to do it I apologize you know like
I'll smack talk to the other guy be like
he'll be like man you ready to lose and
I'd be like [ __ ] that you about to go
down play and I'm like I'm kidding
I'm not I don't really think I'm gonna
win like I'm told yes I might win like I
even on my show i have a show on the
Playboy channel right and we explore
weird sex and one of the episodes I had
to learn how to be a dominatrix and I
don't know anything about this world you
said you're into sports like I went from
pitching you playing badminton imagine
me I'm like so sweet and innocent and
then I have to go in there and then they
they sent me into a dungeon with this
girl that looked like she would beat me
up she first crepe and then there's a
naked guy and not a cute one like old
and like he had a wrinkly but like he
wasn't like a shar-pei but he was like
tied up to this cross thing and then I
they taught me how to whip them with all
these different things and spank him and
you know I felt so bad and then the guy
they want you to be mean to them they
want you to make fun of them they get
off on that they want you to tell them
they're gross and ugly and like that
their dick is small like all this stuff
and I eat every morning that's why I was
self esteems
like this is an appropriate I'm funny by
waiting I'm sorry okay and I'd like kind
of like touch it to like try to make him
feel better wrinkly but what did feel
well but it felt like a loaf of raisin
bread just balls that's my life this is
my life it's like I since I host the
show I used to be very vanilla and now
I'm more like a swirl what was it easy
to make fun of him cuz he did ever ring
Clee ass like if the guy had a great ass
and it was like a body buddy but your
baby like you wrinkly gross ass like
yeah no I'm serious
I really did you know I really didn't
make fun of him I just tried to make the
episode funny by showing how bad I
being mean you know what I mean cuz I
can't I mean I feel guilty I had a guide
message me on Facebook can offer me $700
to watch him jerk off on camera and make
fun of him while he did it five and I
said no and then he kept raising the
price and then when he got to $700 I was
at the Comedy Store
actually this is funny he messaged me I
was at the Comedy Store and I was
telling the other comics and they're
like you got to do it $700 just do it I
was like I can't do it what if he takes
a photo of me like I don't want people
to think I do that kind of thing you
know I was like I'll tell you what I
wrote the guy and I said I bought it for
Half Price
do it right now but I'm gonna do it at
the Comedy Store and I'm gonna let a
bunch of comics watch - but they're
really mean and they all make fun of you
for sure and then he didn't he wouldn't
how did you have his number
no he Facebook messaged me on my face oh
wow creepy don't you get you must get
creepy you must get creepy messages from
fans I said I wanted to watch you eat a
bully yogurt wearing a scuba mask that
was me remember I said I want to watch
you put stick pop-tarts at your butt
it's good my name now is like why did I
come here so you're single yeah I'm
curious because like you're famous you
know like you must get recognized all
the time so for me like I think dating
sucks as a girl because like everybody's
trying to get with you all the time and
it's exhausting and overwhelming and I
just I I don't want to do it but I feel
like for you it must be like a whole
other love I feel being Fame a famous
guy is the closest thing met any man can
experience what it's like to be an
attractive female in the dating game
like that's true
it's got if you're like a hot chick
you're like a hot chick you deal with
the same issues you're a diva
I'm a hot chick diva book why you saying
you don't like dating I hate dating
oh come what's this all about I mean I
why do you hate dating
well when you get free food something
when the guys have money
yeah no thank you because I gotta hit K
top are Ying dongs what's that man broke
and they want her to drive them around
buy them food that's not true those are
just the ones that I usually like or
they have like their nipples pears what
do you mean like okay this is the thing
I don't like dating because I like I
like hanging out people that know me
like my friends like Eric you know it's
like it's fun you know each other you
have a good rapport a good relationship
I don't like dating like I went out on a
date this week for instance and the
problem is by the first 20 minutes
I either I'm really interested in the
conversation or I just want to get the
hell out of there you know where you go
you can't leave where'd you go the guy
took me to a restaurant called Little
Door it's a great place I'm sure you've
been on third Eric you would love this
place when you get money you should
definitely go what is it it's when I get
money
I love these back yet a compliment
please last night we went to Mel's Diner
and I ordered a burger and Eric's like I
can't afford to eat but I'll watch and
he's wearing a Tom Ford suit at Mel's
Diner not eating cuz he's broke that's
why I brought her I bought the frickin
suit wait Hans go take me to a little
door later we're gonna get I'll take
okay we went a little door and basically
the guy he I met him he was in the
audience at a comedy show that was
probably a mistake I feel like you
should never go out with audience
members do you go out with audience
super good-looking guy he's a great
looking guy although I think he's on
steroids I'm pretty sure he's on illegal
steroids super buff but also then like
he okay he was super nice and really
sweet and um but he was like I think
more a fan of the idea of dating a
comedian than like like I felt like he
felt like he knew me because he saw me
on stage but like I'm so different on I
feel like my person on stage isn't
really like necessarily how I really am
like if you follow me on instagram you
probably think that I would like [ __ ]
anybody but actually like I'm like
really picky and like I don't date that
much so what happened at the 20-minute
mark she started a good question okay he
never made me Lala's on point today he
never made me laugh that's the problem
he's really nice he he oh and also like
I had to keep the conversation going
like about I kept asking him questions
about what he does for a living and then
that's the other thing so for a living
he sells he sells basically injectable
like human growth hormone stuff like I I
mean half legal and then he started
telling me I should sell it and I should
try it and then he was like oh it's
really good for your skin and you
wouldn't have to get Botox and you could
just use this instead and like so he
still steroids and he's trying to get
you to sell them and Hawk them what
you're forcing me to he was just telling
me about it and then I'm looking at him
like he does have a great body maybe I
should so then now what happened is to
be honest with you at the end of the
date I kissed him goodbye I felt nothing
it was like kissing you know like my
brother or my uncle or something and
then I left and he's so nice you know
he's like texting me like it was such a
great time you're so great I can't wait
to hang out again and I was like I don't
really want to go on another date with
him but I kind of want the injectables
what are the injectables for he told me
that okay he told me that he sells these
injections that that like he said
there's one that makes your memory
better
there's one that makes you more tan
there's one for your skin there's there
muscle-building ones and fat burner ones
they sound like the most dangerous thing
probably like diet slice you're
injecting into your butt I don't know I
asked him if they're safe and he was
like of course I've been taking them for
a decade and I was like okay but I did
cocaine for like five years and that's
not safe like I don't think just because
you do it means that it safe for five
years not really I'm exaggerating but I
mean the point is I could have quit
doing I quit doing drugs do you have
women hit on you after shows talk more
about but I want to hear about this kiss
though what was it a good kiss I'm sorry
no he had great you putting gum loose it
was gross he's gonna kill himself
was it attracted to him like how how
long did the kiss last like I don't know
five seconds oh so like just like a like
a grandma passed there was a little hint
of tongue oh just a him so you tease
them a little I always a guy on the
first date
do you do you kiss girls on the first
date always oh god I can't remember what
do you what do you do I kiss people in
the subway I just walk up nobody's on a
date I don't know what a date like yes
so my husband and son are joining us and
I'm like so good so text me and he'll be
like so I've gone out with this girl for
coffee twice and I don't know if she
thinks were dating or she thinks or how
you know his friends I'm like what do
you think he's like I hope we're dating
like I'm hoping it's dating and I'm like
you should probably ask her out and tell
her to date like say hey I'd really like
to take you on a proper date like to
dinner well I think you should ask
because I always I'm out with somebody
and I don't
for dis friends and I feel like I'm
getting friendzone but I'm like hey do
you want to go to dinner I feel like
dinner is a date and then they write me
some three paragraph thing about how
they're concentrating on themselves tell
you how you know if you're in the friend
zone with a girl I think I know it's
based on how often she touches you if
I'm out with a guy that I'm attracted to
I'll touch him a few times for sure
coffee and she's across the table she's
supposed to lean oh let me ask my face
no but like when you're waiting in line
it's easy did you see it the guy that I
had in the last podcast how many times I
touched him during the interview I lost
count after 450th and he had like if
you're out with a guy if I'm out with
you at coffee how many times have we
gone out for coffee you and I a million
times Owens have I ever been very touchy
with you know exactly I feel like this
is hurtful and I don't how it is looked
at me like I was the saddest most
pathetic you know I love to cuddle and
we can cuddle at any time Jesus Christ
masculine me any worse on this bike I
would love to cuddle with you Eric what
am i a [ __ ] pound puppy I touched you
at coffee bean I'm like you are usually
like three arm legs away from day and
I've got taser at hand at any time I
mean the point man I almost touched me
more than yeah and he's scared of Zika
virus he's just pointing at me did you
really have that happen you were on a
date husband and the kid you well I did
a show and then after the comedy show
this lady's like I was in like Richmond
Virginia or some [ __ ] and she's like hey
do you want to get do you only at lunch
tomorrow since you're in town all day
and I'm like oh my god so I thought it
was a date but she told the comedy show
and she's like my comedy so we meet at
this restaurant and I walk in and
there's some dude and like a teenage kid
and I was like this could get freaky and
she's like oh is my son Tyler and this
is my husband and the husband's just
giving me the look
like if a guy's hitting on your
girlfriend the look you give the guy
like I will [ __ ] kill you and I'm
like oh that's the comedian honey and I
sit down and she's like oh err do you're
one of your jokes and the guys just like
staring at me and I'm
what the father dude I didn't know she
asked me to lunch I assumed it was a day
but obviously what to him no no God I
didn't say that I just I played it off
like I was like oh she told me a lot
about you I was like I couldn't got it
get out of there fast enough
I feel like married women are always
attracted to you like remember when we
did Brea with Brad William it wasn't
because she was attracted to me some
people just like your comedy and they
want to hang out with you but they might
not find you sexually attract
okay but that not you apparently said
you during that coffee I'm kidding I'm
kidding but the UH no but it's the it's
the but when you go out unless you like
your comedy and you're hanging out in a
group but there there's you know the
girl there's always some guy hanging
around her or you go to some bar and
like Richmond where she goes all the
time and there's always like ten guys
that are in love with her and she's like
oh this is Eric he's the comic and they
look okay I'm like did you ever hook up
with that guy and she's like no but he
likes me but we're just friends and
there's like always like 10 of those
guys at the bar swarming around her like
a shark I mean but people you can have
guy friends that are really just your
friends I think I think that's a
misconception like people think that men
and women are never just platonic like
wouldn't you say you and I are totally
platonic Colin do you have girlfriends
yeah I think that's true like that
you're just friends with yeah yeah right
that you've never even I mean maybe you
think about hooking up with him everyone
smile but you wouldn't do it he's
stroking his beard like a wise wizard do
you have any girlfriends you would not
hook up with if they were like let's do
it
usually at my girlfriends our girls that
I had fun with hooked up before and then
you become man I didn't really you know
I didn't want to keep having fun but we
stayed friends oh I see yeah so you
don't usually that's interesting that
means like women can't keep their hands
off you that's I don't know why you're
pointing a bay oh man
that means that any woman you hang out
with you end up hooking up with
eventually at some point and then become
friends no no I'm not saying that Oh
Harlan is a well-known lothario on the
street well no but I mean if all if most
of your girlfriend's you hooked up with
at some point that means that's they
couldn't oh it started out like you
started out dating I don't know I feel
like if you're gonna spend time with
someone you should really get to know
them yeah no I like yeah like know them
like no they're the curvature of their
body they're so inspired I was like
exactly that's I'm saying get to know
them right into like okay carlin have
you ever even even growing up did you
ever like even like high school and
middle school have a girl you had a huge
crush on and you were talking about she
put you in the friend zone but you would
like kept hanging out there because you
thought maybe she would change her mind
do you know what I mean is that has that
ever been a thing I had one girl like
that yeah I just I couldn't what's her
name and address well I just confronted
it I just said I'm not gonna not gonna
stand around in the fumes I'm just gonna
confront her and just tell her how I
feel and if she goes for it cool if not
then adios yeah Wow no and what happened
I I took her out to the country was like
late at night you market her we found an
old church out in the middle of the
nowhere and it was late and we sat on
the church steps it was like a little
country church nothing around Wow and I
told her I said look I got to tell you
this cuz it's it's I just have to I said
I love you yeah and I said you know I
don't know what you're gonna do with it
but I I need I need you to know and she
said I think you're really great I think
you're nice this is when I was I think
as a teen at the time Wow and she said
you're really cool and but I don't feel
the same
yeah and I said you know I feel great
because I got it out you know I said it
yeah that's amazing I've never had a guy
do that to me that's a that's ballsy did
you still hang it after that or not uh
yeah I ended up I was able to you know
kind of you know school end because this
was like you know grade 12 grade 13 so
great 13 is that a Canadian thing okay
third grade me they did when I was
growing up they did yeah and so weird
but but yeah but then I you know was
interesting I found out later a few
years later that one of her good friends
and my good friends it's kind of a you
know this eased the pain alone our Co
friend said to me at a party one night
she goes you know Judy would have gone
out with you if you had been into drugs
what that's crazy
sir time at the type was like the hippie
the burnout she just I think she liked
the guy they'd like to crank it up and
do drugs and stuff so you know I think I
heard that you don't smoke weed at all
but it cause the movie half-baked people
assumed that about you yeah that's right
but you it was never you never cared for
it yeah whatever thank you automatically
assume you were stoned right funny Dave
Chappelle said that too is like every
time I do want to interview something
feel like are you high right now no yeah
do you drink it all harlot little have
some beers awesome beer and sake oh yeah
that's it that's all I drink I like Eric
sober I quit drinking recently and I
that's the other thing
dating sober sucks yeah yeah like I
didn't even think about that like I I
like the other night when I was out I
feel like when you don't drink people
look at you like you're weird you know
people think they expect you to drink
and then also if the date isn't fun a
drink is a great way to like loosen it
up right oh if I could only drink all
these days it make things so much better
you'd be way looser and then also I mean
it tank I they carry me out of the
sizzler I'm trying really hard like this
is where I thought you were going with
your sweet sentiment about getting to
know people but obviously not I'm trying
really hard to to get to know people way
more before I hook up with them now like
that's my new thing I'll catch another
last name no I really like cuz I have a
problem with I think I hook up with
people too fast and I don't even hook up
that fast it's usually like the third or
fourth day like it's never before that
yeah but I hook up with them before I
know them that well and I'm one of those
girls that like if the sex is really
good I really confuse it with like
feelings like I get feelings like you
guys can just like [ __ ] and feel nothing
we can't I can't do that I can if you're
not good so like my booty calls are very
mediocre I'm not gonna lie I keep booty
calls that are like decent at sex but
not great so that I don't get feelings
for them how late is your booty when you
say booty call what time of night is
that well actually weirdly enough like
like midnight though you're not a real
night out no I mean the booty call the
one booty call I have that's the best we
have to schedule it because he's so busy
and I'm so busy that will actually
schedule it in advance and it's usually
during the day oh okay that's good it's
usually like you can just schedule sex
today no no no actually I even stopped
hitting up my booty call so I had this
moment I had this moment where I had a
we have a booty call playing on your
phone I ate a week for discount only ten
cents a minute no I had a moment well it
felt like I was partying too much I was
making poor life choices and I was
depressed and I was like why am I
depressed my life is going great my
career's going well like people are do
better at acting on Memorial Day
you love me and I was like you said be
like three paragraphs and one point
there was like I'll haiku in there I was
like Kate as my face was like the wind
on a soft summer's old man Capri sodden
and is in I'm paraphrasing but it was
beautiful they could have been a hit
song by Gordon Lightfoot I sent you a
Texas I'd like hurt you that's it I say
you do you want me to read the text
whatever the point that you can't I
don't care it the point is I decided to
take a break from everything so for like
maybe I think two weeks
I didn't even masturbate like nothing I
didn't drink do any drugs have any sex
masturbate nothing for like two weeks I
was trying to like clear my head yeah
sounds like a horror movie I know no
masturbation for two weeks will he
survive but the point is after that I
decided I was gonna make a lifestyle
change so I stopped hitting up my booty
calls even know were they pissed oh my
god it's so funny cuz the one guy the
one good he know he never really like
text me more than like emojis or maybe
one or two words at a time and then all
of a sudden it was like he was like a
Harvard scholar like the [ __ ] he was
coming up with I was like did this guy
go to school for debate like he should
be an attorney like he had so many great
reasons for why my plan was awful but
they can't be mad they're never there
just booty they're the reason there's
only two of them and the reason they're
a booty call category is one is in like
an open relationship so he has a girl so
it would never be like more than a thing
and I'm the other one is just he's just
so dumb that I could never date him just
a dumb [ __ ] yeah but the point is their
guard I booted them I'm good at the
booty calls there's no more boot I have
no booty calls now I'm only sleeping
with guys I actually like that I
actually get to know so what I'm saying
is I'm a virgin again basically Wow
like a ziplock do you have any booty
calls Harlan yeah what's your deal what
do you say for it - your booty calls I
don't have a booty call thing I don't
stay up that late doesn't have to be
nice yeah you're right yeah I shouldn't
you know what I should do is I know once
a time thing yeah what time of day do
you do it well I don't do you recommend
30 your food digest your sandwich and
then you could get naked and then you
have to rest up for dinner
I like mid-afternoon like a happy hour
an hour about snack times I don't
actually like daytime I like number of a
coffee brah
I like nighttime sex I love sex late at
night right cuz then afterwards if the
core if you like the person okay if it's
a booty call
I like late at night because then
outdoors I'd kick them out and pass out
right if it's not a booty call
I like late at night because then
afterwards I can sleep there and then
have more sex in the morning oh you like
that morning stop I never used to but I
recently grew into it why why what why
did you go into the morning stuff
because I'm in my 30s now and I just
want to [ __ ] all the time good morning
what's wrong about morning about morning
sex is that girls when I spend the night
at a guy's place no girls get up in the
morning well you're still like basically
dead to the world
and we sneak into your bathroom and we
make ourselves presentable and then we
come back to bed so that you think
that's just how we are y'all you sleep
with your makeup on and everything I
don't sleep with makeup on no but I will
go I will go in the bathroom in the
morning and like brush my teeth and like
make sure I don't have [ __ ] in my eyes
and like brush my hair get rid of the
Hmong yeah I get rid of it and then I
come back to bed and then they just
think like oh she just wakes up like
that I wake up in the middle of the
night and put on moisturizers and lip
gloss when I wake up I look sensation
but you look Wow yeah well they're
they're like is that George Clooney's
and I'm like it's just me but what about
the dude though he's all bummed out with
the morning breath on us grossie's the
crunchy lakes yeah there's no there's
nothing that happens during the morning
tourism no you know his mouth smells
like there's a penis oh you don't I
thought guys loved morning sex I don't -
monkey really oh yeah I used to not like
it that's before 6:00 p.m. I have a
question for you forget morning sex I
want to know how do you meet women
before you date a fan first of all would
you date a fan let's say somebody hit
you up like the way this guy this
audience guy hit me up after the show on
Instagram and he was like I saw you
tonight you're so funny and I've never
gone out with an audience member before
but he is really hot so I was like [ __ ]
it super he was like you said he worked
out like crazy right yeah he looks like
like a full like a Venice Beach guy is
that what you're talking about is like
the rock did you do you didn't see with
his top off though well his he has
Instagram pictures I have no you didn't
do that you went through his Instagram
he followed me on Instagram and he was
like I'd love to take you out so I had
to look at his photos to see what he
looked like was he like topless and
stuff yeah his instagrams are pretty big
turned off they were his photos are
great he's hot six-pack yeah but every
photo is a selfie of him at the gym and
I wasn't gonna go out with them because
of that cuz that's gross to me like I'm
not into that you know into what guys
that post too many like gym selfies and
just selfies in general yeah I'm just
great with my gym selfies I'll be one
shut off one a week
does it give em a little taste and one
pants off and then woven no sauce yeah
just though they get a little glimpse of
the Eric behind the curtain so it's cuz
I hear a lot of girls don't know you
always hear girls say I don't like the
big yes guys but I'm like why not what's
wrong the buff guys buff is good too
buff is bad this guy's too buff out
like hulkees icult yeah he's like like
bodybuilder like veins like that doesn't
excite girls not me what it's too much
every girl wants a guy that's in shape
but that's too much what I'd like a
six-pack I like muscles but I'm we're
talking like bodybuilder like no body
fat what it does it just feel gross like
is it feel like you're you're screwing
an Anatomy project when I see a guy
that's that big I assume he's on
steroids and his dick doesn't work is
that is that true
is that is that a true scientific fact I
can save on personal experience yeah my
PS fell off in 2003 what it's not just
that there's just something it's just
they don't look like someone you want to
like cuddle up with really yeah I know
I like muscles don't get me wrong like I
love athlete it's like I'm super into
that but but too much
it's the same with girls though right
like you want a girl tits fit but do you
want to grow it looks like she's a body
better
you nailed it yeah you don't want to you
don't be the girl that you know look
feels like a guy do you do you my
personal business is concerned I want a
girl that looks like Lou Ferrigno what
do you want to get ya know now I would
you want a girl with man boobs I met
this girl on bumble and she's a
bodybuilder and she's like really
freaking Brit like your arms are like
obviously I'm not huge and her arms like
huge and her shoulder like she has all
these pictures oh did you puke no I
didn't I think she's cute but she's like
really really ripped and then she's like
she's like aggressive on the thing so
we're supposed to have launch but then
I'm like what is she like beats me R
kidnaps I could see you being into like
No
what's that Eric on an episode of date
fails and we had like this dominatrix
chick because I don't know why I think
Eric would be like a great submissive
and like a girl it's like a dominant
woman he was so he was texting me
afterwards like that pitch was scary why
it hurts like I can wear belts anymore
if I even see about they start screaming
suspenders anything garters are you
attracted a dominant women like
dominatrix types would you be into that
I'd give it a shot I mean I you know I I
kind of let just chemistry unfold yeah
you never know what a person is until
you spend time with them and yeah and
you see how it plays out this is true do
you have any deal-breakers is there
anything that like immediately you'd be
like oh hell yeah breath yeah breath you
can't do I'm with you on that
do you a certain type of girl you like
you're at all guys do you like tall
girls or do no III don't it doesn't
matter it's all about you know that kind
of so a little bit of a chemistry thing
mastering a little little will spark I
mean I have a fetish for women that say
yes that's all yes and a pulse and the
pulses negotiable
we're having fun we're having fun I
really like guys that are loose with
compliments cuz I give a lot of
compliments yeah yeah I can't help it
it's just the way I am let me not get
into that
case I look great one day I felt great
and then there's other dude was walking
around the comedy store he looked like
[ __ ] she's like you look great and I was
like god dammit I only said if I mean it
though I don't I don't blow smoke at
people so I guy if I don't think
something like if you're a girl and you
have on a cute outfit I'm like I love
your outfit I wouldn't just say it if it
wasn't true
but I am loose with compliments and so
like when I'm dating someone especially
like I'm always giving the guy
compliments but I'm attracted to guys
that don't give them back I don't know
why really yeah I don't want to because
I hate it so it makes me feel shitty
like I'll be like you're so hot and then
they'll just be like thank you and not
say anything back and then on the inside
why don't they ever compliment me back
but that must be my what I'm into cuz I
always am attracted to those guys so if
I say oh your hair looks great you're
like yeah this guy here's the problem
like I want that from the guys that
don't want to do it this is a [ __ ]
freaking mind
mock [ __ ] you're crazy
what do you have do you have women that
when you go on dates with them they
expect you to be like a comic the whole
time or on or funny the whole time oh it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter what
you want what they want yeah yes yeah
I'm just gonna be me but you seem like a
guy that would like likes to goof around
just for fun I like to I like to you
know have fun and have a laugh but I'm
not gonna lie gonna put on clown shoes
to make some girl you know if she she
wants funny yeah you know go get a
shovel at Home Depot and dig up Phyllis
Diller do you have girls that when you
go out with them that try to talk to you
about comedy the whole time or try to
like that's the way movies or anything
really I tried to steer away from that
stuff you're so lucky
why cuz I feel like that's because women
I don't think we don't try to impress me
when we go on a date your job is to
impress us right so we just kind of like
I mean it's the truth like we don't have
to work to impress you like you you are
impressed enough to take us out so now
it's like your job listen all I'm saying
is this like the guys are always trying
to impress the woman I'm not like that
I sit back and I'm more like impressed
me I know I'm not gonna do that it's
like you know show me what you got but
you top this but you talk like you
probably ask questions and things oh
yeah okay just just like the guy went
out with the other day it was just my
body's like it turns me off like I think
guys try too hard oh you don't do that
no it's too funny where's your ideal
what's your ideal date like what do you
like to do on a date I like going to the
ArcLight I'm going to the meet you
Hollywood are client of the Hollywood
are quiet that's my favorite date spot
they like wait on you there right what
don't they wait on you there no oh you
mean just like a traditional date like a
normal day yeah yeah what about a first
date yeah I could go there I mean uh I'm
open to anything on a day you know it
could be a road trip to across America
or it could be it could be a movie
theater yeah now imagine 20 minutes into
that if you're like I'm not into this
person yeah you deal with it I kind of
like the idea of a trip dude that's a
great idea what if like on date Nook
like you have a good first date and
you're like all right let's see what's
up let's go away for a weekend that's a
bit dating show like you gotta get a car
with somebody go across country whoever
makes it the further road trips are the
best date ever
well and it's the best way to find out
if you really like
have a thing with someone you travel
with them for a weekend you know right
away because an hour in when the air
conditionings not working or stuck in
traffic you see you see that real person
what do you do if you know if you're not
into it though like what do you do if
day two you're like oh yeah what's the
worst date you've ever had
besides this yes well I took Harlan out
for beanie weenies one night many do you
want
you are aware I mean remember we went
out to Wiener schnitzel can you think of
a really awful date or a bad like
horrific any horrific dating experience
sexual experience something did however
like it you wouldn't unchecks what you
didn't have I can give you one if you
need to think my worst probably there
been a couple but okay the worst sex
story ever I went out with this guy a
few times three or four times I liked
him he was cool we connected he was cute
but I will say we made out but when I
was buzzed it was good but when I was
sober it was just Nick so I probably
should have known you know younger uh
Hughes order just a few years yeah yeah
so anyway like the fourth or fifth date
he invites me to his place he's like
I'll make you dinner which is like the
sex date right so I know going in what
the sex date weight dinner means sex I
mean I feel like after four or five
dates if a guy invites you to his place
he's assuming sex you're not okay okay
if I don't live with my parents then
yeah okay I mean he made dinner and then
we started you know hooking up and then
I was like oh yeah meatballs if you know
what I'm saying we had sex
because I felt obligated I didn't even
want to it was like guilt it was like
guilt sucks I've done that a couple
times where I feel bad so I'll just do
it because I feel like guilt sacked yeah
made you dinner yeah he took me out and
like nice
dates and I just felt like kind of like
okay well I can om but why was this one
in particular the worst was the only oh
why was it the bad sex Bob because then
what happened is so we started having
sex he turns off the TV he turns off all
the sound there's no sound in his
apartment no music no TV and then also
he made no sound no sound like it was
like a silent film it was like on mute
they become black and white all yeah and
then he was really bad at sex like I
felt like he was reading instructions as
he went like that's really how it felt
like step one kiss her step to kiss her
no he was listening sound yeah so he
does the whole thing what he's supposed
to do you know we have sex and then it
was so bad you know he's like get on top
so I just faked it so that you know
faked being done so he would finish so I
could leave yeah how long did you give
him before you did the fake I gave him
maybe I don't know 20 minutes 10 minutes
10 minutes nice person see I've heard
about this one describe the fake like
what what does one do when that okay
here's why I had to fake it I'm on top
of him I'm I bit his neck okay I put him
on the neck and he said ow
I was like that hurts he's like I have
really sensitive skin wait a minute the
fact that you bit him I was trying to
get you trying to get into it quite a
guy that's the kiss of death
I will try really hard to make it good
yeah and then you know I'm like maybe I
can get into a little biting point is I
had to fake it after he said ow cuz
that's the biggest turnoff like don't
say like even if it hurts like I don't
know
say oh come over the safe word I say
Jeepers Creepers so whenever I say
vagina right so I faked it and I get all
and he finishes and then whatever and
then I'm like how do I get out of here
so I I get off him and then he goes into
the bathroom and then he looks in he
looks in the mirror and I guys I had bit
him a little harder than I thought
because I left a mark Lord Jesus that
hard and then he was like I have really
sensitive skin it's okay and I was like
I'm sorry I have a really he's like I
have a really important meeting tomorrow
do you have some makeup you can leave
here like no and I was like I can't
that was me Harlan so let's guy I'm
scared
pump pump I need it for my mother what's
what's the fake orgasm thing how does
that work let's fake it like you just
make a noise you make noises you act
like you're having one and then you're
done is there any weird guilt when
you're doing it no should there be I'm
just asking here's the thing I think
women shouldn't do it and I know that I
do it and I feel bad about it because I
think the reason we shouldn't is because
guys don't sometimes ever learn how to
get a girl off because women fake it so
often that guys don't they think they're
getting you off and they aren't so then
they never learn how to be good at sex
so I actually think we'd be doing women
a favor if all women stopped faking it
but sometimes you just got to to get out
of there
but your woman always it's true Quigley
do women always make noise when they I
don't know I'm only one person all right
I mean I don't I can't speak for all
women I make a lot of noise I'm loud in
general well listen I'm just loud scream
loud or moan loud I say class dismissed
when you when you when you achieve when
I achieve the height of pleasure I go
class dismissed or Adult Swim or happy
Wednesday he's freaky
we need to hear your worst date yeah
yeah what is it do you have a bad one or
bad sex story crazy anything I have one
not too long ago I was in a rubra and I
was on a boat with a woman like a murder
mystery it was pretty close okay there
was some other people on the boat there
was some some some young girls in
bikinis oh and she asked me to look at
them cuz she said oh look at their fake
boobs
yeah I looked I said you want me to look
at she goes yeah so I looked I said okay
no big deal crap what fake boobs I
didn't see two young girls in bikinis
playing volleyball with green hair yes I
went in swimming I went snorkeling hmm
and when I got back on the boat she like
ripped into me no like no one's ever
talked to me this way my whole life she
just went off about you looking at the
girls yeah that she asked you to look at
right right that's not I go alert yeah
and I never had anyone talked to me like
that in my entire life Wow she was just
ripping you just just crazy stuff I've
never heard and me and venomous like the
anger in her voice and so I literally
grabbed her by the arms and said you
need to calm down immediately yeah oh
that probably didn't know and it did
help for about four minutes she walked
away I mean came back and started again
so I went down into the galley
I grabbed my flip-flops and my hat and
the hotel key out of her purse I go for
a swim to shore
it was probably like 60 yards oh my god
climbed up the rocks walked three wheels
bonad that's what I said to my buddy I
felt like James
three miles down a dirt road to the
hotel as I'm packing my bag I'm on the
line to my travel agent yeah I was in
the air on the way back to the United
States before her boat got back oh are
you serious for real you were like I'm
Audi I just won gone that sound like
Jason Bourne
I don't off the boat I've killed a shark
and wore a skin for that let people you
can't let people you know abuse you or
talk down I know man that's awesome Wow
was pretty in town that's a perfect day
pal
yeah no that's a pretty good date fail
yeah okay got snippy with me at the
sizzler and I hey who crawled through
the air vent left off the roof chartered
a helicopter all right and I was I was I
love this I do like this we all love
sailor should sponsor this show we talk
about every episode
I love the sizzle actually last night it
says alert well I won't get into that
story but it was none too good
why don't we save that for the next
episode because we have to wrap it up
there's another show coming in and I
just I love Harlan's story that was like
a perfect ending that was so close
this has been amazing thank you so much
for being here thank you everyone of
course follow Harland
it's just at Harlan Williams right yeah
and Eric at Eric Myers comedy yeah
court-ordered cartoon check out on
YouTube quartered watches cartoon I'm
gonna be a judge I'm gonna whoop some
ass Harley you should be on my cartoon
series I'll tell you all about it yeah
okay all right everybody love you I'm
Kate quickly follow me at Kate cute
funny see you next time on date bears
bye yeppers dude that story